[Música]
[Aplausos]
tengo dos pasiones en esta vida
desde niño me inculcaron ese amor por la
naturaleza en casa de mis abuelos
maternos tengo una estantería a la que
yo siempre iba cada vez que tenía
curiosidad sobre algún tema entre textos
y enciclopedias libros imágenes me
terminó gustando mucho aprender sobre la
naturaleza y la ciencia y en especial
sobre el océano y la vida marina allí
nació mi primera pasión la naturaleza
a medida que fui creciendo y todos estos
conocimientos se fueron acumulando en mi
desperté esa empatía por la madre
tierra' pero antes de descubrir que lo
que quería hacer en la vida es ser
fotógrafo submarino pasé un tiempo en mi
juventud desconectado de mi mundo
interior de esa parte de mí que ama la
naturaleza por eso también me sirvió de
escalón y fue la razón por la cual entré
a la escuela de comunicación allí nace
mi segunda pasión querer ser fotógrafo
submarino
esta era en la que vivimos digital e
interconectada nos ha permitido percibir
avances que suceden en otras partes del
mundo
llevo dos años participando de fundación
naturaleza panamá nos dedicamos a
investigar qué áreas de manglar en las
costas panameñas necesitan ser
reforestadas y trabajamos en torno a
ellos ecosistemas de manglar
poder percibir deforestación
contaminación me dejó una huella
indeleble en mi corazón y en mi mente
en algunas de estas áreas también
percibí desinterés por parte de las
personas que viven en el lugar
no pienso que se desinterés fuera porque
sean malas personas pero quizá porque no
tenía las herramientas para entender lo
que sucedía en su entorno y para
entender el panorama global desde una
perspectiva más amplia
así que ese tiempo participando en
fundación naturaleza me permite no solo
enriquecer mi conocimiento como
fotógrafo y como comunicador sino
también como ser humano me permite
llegar a ellos conocerles saber qué
necesidades tienen y también me permitió
ver dentro de mí y adoptar una
perspectiva distinta saber de que tenía
una labor como ser humano y como
comunicador
aunque muchos de nosotros ya saben y
entienden que el punto de no retorno
para el desequilibrio de los ecosistemas
en la tierra está a la vuelta de la
esquina aún hace falta que todos y cada
uno de nosotros ponga de su parte dentro
de sus posibilidades para poder marcar
la diferencia entre el futuro que se nos
avecina
la era digital nos permite ser creadores
de contenido de información nos capacita
para difundir nuestra voz ampliamente y
permite también que otros pueden alzar
su voz indistintamente de donde se
encuentran en el planeta ejemplo de ello
hemos visto como este año muchos jóvenes
alrededor del mundo han tomado las
calles incluso ciudades enteras para
comunicar su inconformidad frente a la
desigualdad que aqueja a todo el planeta
también para comunicar que es muy tóxico
esos modelos de consumo que hemos venido
adoptando a lo largo de los últimos años
modelos de consumo que también provocan
desigualdad económica social racial y de
género
a medida que me puse a investigar sobre
cómo funcionaba mi entorno digital
encontrar algunas carencias propias del
entorno digital en una investigación
realizada por la universidad de harvard
y carolina del sur encontré algunas de
estas les voy a compartir tres hoy ellos
plasman el resultado de su investigación
en un documento llamado nuestro espacio
ser un ciudadano responsable del entorno
digital
la primera de ellas es la brecha digital
o el hecho de que no todos en el planeta
tengan igual acceso a la tecnología y
por tanto queden rezagados por no saber
usarla
este señor tiene 81 años viven en la
calle zapatilla norte está encargado de
vigilar el desove y eclosión de la
tortuga carey
me senté a hablar más o menos una hora
con él y aprendí cosas maravillosas
aprendí que cayó zapatilla antes eran
tres ahora son 2
él ha percibido los enormes cambios que
se han suscitado en los últimos años y
especialmente en los últimos cinco años
en su entorno
él no tiene teléfono móvil no tiene
computadora no tiene acceso a internet
pero sabe lo que pasa en su entorno e
intuye que algo muy grande está
sucediendo en el planeta verán según
números de wire social' y hot sweet
alrededor del mundo sólo el 57 por
ciento de nosotros tiene acceso a
internet de esto se trata la brecha
digital que está muy lejos de cerrarse
todavía
eso nos convierte a nosotros individuos
del entorno digital personas
privilegiadas
la experiencia que compartí con él
durante esa hora a hora y media hablando
en calle zapatilla norte también dejó
una huella indeleble en mí
me confirmó que tenía un deber como
individuo de comunicarlo a ustedes y al
mundo lo que sucede no solo en
ecosistemas panameños sino cómo esto se
repite en todas las otras partes del
mundo
el otro aspecto importante que encontré
es la identidad digital
esto fue en una actividad de fundación
mimar yo participo de fundación y marc
desde principios de abril
en fundación mimar a base de actividades
para todo público pero en especial para
niños fomentamos crear esto que yo llamo
conciencia ecológica colectiva
esta niña ríe porque su mamá la acaba de
recordar que ha olvidado ponerle las
baterías a su recién construidos robots
reciclados y con estos tipos de
actividades con estas formas de
interactuar con los niños de enseñarles
que hay un problema con el medio
ambiente que deben ser conscientes y que
también es importante cada una de las
cosas que ellos aportan
somos responsables de permitirle a esos
jóvenes forjarse una identidad humana y
digital ligada a una conciencia
ecológica colectiva que es tan necesaria
frente a este panorama que vivimos
según números de unicef 346 millones de
niños y jóvenes en todo el mundo no
tienen acceso a internet eso hace como
les decía hace un momento que ella y
todos los que participamos del entorno
digital seamos personas privilegiadas
tener acceso a esta tecnología y así
información conlleva un deber y una
responsabilidad
el último punto fue la ética en el
entorno digital
pienso que todos necesitamos adoptar
este enfoque de conciencia ecológica
colectiva
verán todos nosotros estamos siendo
bombardeados cada días de montañas de
información y entre tanta información sé
que a veces es difícil diferenciar entre
información y desinformación cuanto más
difíciles será para los jóvenes y niños
que pasan muchas horas conectados
tener acceso a la tecnología y usarla no
es garantía de emplear la de la mejor
manera
vemos informaciones de cosas que suceden
en otras partes del mundo y que también
tocan nuestra identidad en lo digital es
importante que entendamos nuestra labor
de hablar de las cosas que hay que
hablar de no tener pena no tener miedo
de comunicar estos problemas que nos
afectan a todos como civilización esta
extinción masiva a la que nos
enfrentamos
pasar cuatro días en cada zapatilla surf
parte del parque nacional marino isla
bastimentos marcó mi vida para siempre
puede percibir cómo ambos cayos están
perdiendo de dos a tres pies al año esto
no sólo representa una terrible
consecuencia para el desove y eclosión
de la tortuga carey sino para todas las
otras especies actualmente a través de
fundación naturaleza a panamá intentamos
trabajar y reforestar este entorno pero
así como pasa allí pasa en todo el
planeta
ya no es cosa de solucionar eventos
aislados y es algo que nos compete a
todos y cada uno de nosotros
creo que tenemos el deber de usar las
herramientas esa poderosa herramienta
que es la tecnología para impactar
positivamente en la vida de todos en
nuestra comunidad real y digital también
ayudar a cerrar esa brecha digital ya
permitirle a los jóvenes forjarse una
identidad digital con una ética y una
moral como base conciencia ecológica
colectiva pretende ser un enfoque que
trabaje de manera individual para
impactar colectivamente
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]